jo leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
kleinen runde verstecken spielen wie oh
ich bin ein räuber ja ich bin so ein
campus der läuft überhaupt nicht bei mir
und ja wir haben diese rolle jetzt
gemacht um ein klein wenig etwas zu
besprechen und eure meinung ist gefragt
das heißt bleibt dran
wir werden euch gleich erzählen worum es
geht und ich muss sagen was ihr davon
haltet
davon wird abhängen ob dieses neue
projekt kommt und ja ich will sagen wir
starten direkt mal mit mit ja mit der
erzählung ja und zwar geht es darum dass
wir uns gedacht haben
es wäre einfach richtig geil mal so eine
parodien serie zu starten
beziehungsweise einfach nur ja ein paar
parodien zu machen wir haben daniel bock
drauf weil ihr kennt vielleicht auch
guckt irgendwelche youtuber an und denkt
ja aber das ist jetzt kann man richtig
behindert was er da macht oder das
irgendwie lustig und uns geht so wir
haben einfach lust das nachzumachen und
die frage geht jetzt an euch was haltet
ihr davon habt ihr bock auf seine
parodien serie
wir haben heute schon erste test
aufnahme gemacht das ist richtig lustig
und ja wenn ihr bock drauf habt schreibt
jetzt in die kommentare
lasst uns das wissen davon wellness
abhängig machen ob es kommt oder nicht
das gilt auch für meine leute also wenn
ihr darauf bock gehabt so dass dann halt
von uns zu sehen dann schreibt einfach
in die kommentare und das leica oder so
oder keine ahnung ja um die wirklichkeit
persönlich darüber freuen wenn die
darauf wartet weil wir haben da halt wie
gesagt auf bock und das richtig deutsch
dann ist das halt auch mega lustig
gewesen ja ja wir haben heute wie gesagt
schon eine testfrage gemacht und haben
versucht das ein oder andere youtuber
duo zu imitieren
und ja es ist ich sage das ist richtig
lustig also wirklich wir haben uns schon
ordentlich weg geschätzt und ja wir
glauben dass es euch auch spaß machen
könnte
deswegen fragen wir
ob jetzt bock drauf habt also wie gesagt
wenn er sowas wollte mitmachen wollte
und ein bisschen comedy sehen wollt dann
schreibt das jetzt auf jeden fall in die
kommentare lasst uns wissen es ist
wirklich wichtig also falls ihr bock
drauf habt jetzt in die kommentare
session und schreiben ja ich habe bock
oder eben kein bock die [ __ ] so
was ja auch okay ach ja ja ja also ich
lebe noch so ich hab auch noch so gerade
noch so ich finde das beste leben ist
nämlich dass man als blog unter wasser
keinen schaden bekommen natürlich mich
hier unter die erde und macht ein
bisschen live schilling kommen wir
wissen ja ja und jung hinzu der am
busbahnhof weiter ausbauen muss ja
weiter kommt ist einfach so block
eingelaufen schüler wenn die nägel nicht
der inhalt aber nicht an haider hat wenn
ich ziegler sieht denn bei mir so wie
sie gehören bei mir jetzt eine
rekordsumme verteidigt abstiegszone wird
da gebe ich mir da nicht so kenne ich
nicht an durchbringen
dann bricht sein genick junge brecht
sein genick der action
überall sind die hier aber die sind
einfach dumm dumm sind die zudem viel zu
durchsichtig hängen geblieben ich recht
ist muss die tür wieder aufmachen damit
die denken
organe
ja am besten die tür zumachen zum raum
wurde ich versteckte tür aufmachen
doch weil die dann denken so er ist
dadurch gelaufen wenn die tür auf was
denken sie jetzt durch gelaufen was da
los war
ja wenn die auf ist das heißt du musst
die zu machen ja aber die sollen doch
denken dass ich hier nur durch gelaufen
sind
nun ja nicht fließt hin dass ich hier
drin
okay das wasser weg geschlagen hast du
geld hast passt nun 101 sieg oder an
haider keine ahnung ich war ja
quergestellt noch bleibt ist der beste
lebende ja aber andererseits kann man
dann kein ja keinen dingsdag einziger
von hinten angreifen weil der flug übels
weg gesetzt wird vom jet besuchen das
nicht sogar unter der brücke aber wo
bist du froh die stimmung nach essig
maria blätter sind alter leid
denkst du kannst dich verarscht kann es
aber nicht
walter ja ja ja also das war's nicht
viel was es nicht es gibt ja noch heidi
oder ja gibt es auch haider ich sehe da
keinen countdown gibt noch fünf stirbt
ja gar nichts mehr geheim
ich würde schon mal sagen von mir aus
haut da rein leute wenn es euch gefallen
hat lassen gleich und abu dhabis und ach
so ja es geht auf channel auflieger und
du war ich halt ab und so du weißt ja
wir machen jetzt ja noch ein was da los
alter schon vorbei erheblich jetzt ein
bisschen lobby action hier von mir
willst du den kleinen lobby dance macher
weiß nicht ob er ihn kennt den lobby
dance er ist crazy der gezwungen oder
gegen das ist das ist ungefähr so wie
jump style ja und halb es gab mal wieder
längst ein alter hut diese buben 12
springt einfach random na ja er war also
gut fertig getanzt dann bauen wir ein
schreibt wie gesagt schreibt unbedingt
in die kommentare was ihr von dieser von
diesem parodie projekt haltet lasst uns
das wissen und in diesem sinne macht's
gut und haut rein